hi live chairman
thank you good evening and welcome to
this
northwestern area planning committee
meeting on today wednesday the 21st of
october 2020.
my name's councillor mrs maddie thompson
i'm the chairman of this committee
i'm actually going to go off peace for a
moment because this is in fact the last
northwest before the statutory annual
um and i would like to thank at the
beginning rather than the end when
everyone's in a rush to get off
i would like to thank all the officers
and the members
for all their work and support and
everything they've done
over this last actually year and a half
right back to the script this meeting is
held under new regulations which came
into effect on
4th of april in response to the kogig 19
pandemic
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through first of all please could
i ask everyone
present in the meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted and your video
feed off when not addressing the
committee
this will help reduce background noises
and avoid any unintentional disturbances
the meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live and recorded
and by being present in the meeting
you're giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function of the
meeting to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then like invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak or that you
have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or any other purpose
members when speaking and referring to
agenda papers
please reference a page or paragraph
number and keep your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible
when invited to speak please ensure you
turn on your microphone
and video if that's possible now may i
ask officers taking part to introduce
themselves starting off with mr lee
good evening members i'm matthew lee
lead specialist place and chief planning
officer at modern district council
thank you thank you i believe we haven't
got mr johnson after all so that's
correct
moving on um please
uh good evening i'm hannah bowles i'm a
specialist in development management
thank you
um mrs parker haynes please
members i'm hayley parker-haynes and i'm
a senior caseworker in development
management
thank you mr
good evening members my name is katie
fuller i'm clark for this evening's
committee
thank you any other officers present as
part of this
meeting as opposed to supporting it
thank you um katie could you please
carry out a roll call of members to
confirm who is in attendance
yes chairman members i will call your
name in alphabetical order
please could you indicate if you are
present starting with
councillor bamford
thank you i'm here sorry
i am at the meeting and welcome thank
you
councillor durham
council oh yes i'm present and correct
and yes good evening all right
thank you uh councillor mrs fleming
hi yes present thank you
councillor jarvis
evening members chairman
good evening councillor morley
good evening everyone yeah president
thank you good evening
councillor
good evening katie present good evening
councilman mrs thompson i'm certainly
here
thank you thank you and councillor miss
white
good evening i'm present thank you
um thank you um i know there's one other
member
um present i'm just attending the
meeting so
council morris would you care to
introduce yourself
good evening everybody and welcome good
evening
uh oh i'll just possibly count the
stamps yeah
thank you uh yes please uh
thank you chairman i'm also listening
councillor wendy stan
that's councillor wendy's stamp thank
you is there anyone else any other
member in attendance that
nobody's mentioned yet no okay thank you
moving on
um apologies for absence um i think
we're a full house are we katie
no we have apologies from councillor
keys
oh yes how could i not notice thank you
um right minutes of the 23rd of
september it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 23rd
of september
found on pages 7 to 12 are approved as a
true and
accurate record members may take them as
read
right so i will take those as as um
as agreed and sign them in the fullness
of time thank you
uh right declarations of interest item
four i have to read this bit out
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded they're also
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise during the meeting
um
councillor durham i'm sure you have your
youtube i'm
just i'm just logging in
um yes uh good evening
um i have a non-pecuniary interest
uh as a member of essex county council
who are statutory consultees
planning matters i also need to declare
that i have a pecuniary interest
on item six on the basis that
the uh the estate
is my next-door neighbor and my parents
are landowners
on some of the land that this uh
application
refers so a chairman if it with your
permission i will leave the meeting
permanently after the uh first item
okay thank you very much and i have
council of hanford
thank you chairman i have a
non-pecuniary interest
in agenda item six as i know um
mark durham's parents mr and mrs durham
who live
on the estate thank you actually for
that matter then
um i better include myself to know mr
and mrs gone
um but only socially
any other declarations okay thank you
moving on um the first item of planning
is item five on our agenda
lodge farm lodge road paisley
the uh details can be found on pages 13
to 26.
in a moment i will call on the officer
to present this item
um i do know we have a member of the
public
who is hoping to to speak
um that would be mr ford the agent um
ah i'm being asked if we could adjourn
for a moment
in order to uh
i can't read the rest of it sorry tara
but to sort out the technical issues for
mr ford i presume
um members i'm going to assume your
agreement
and a german meeting at
6 1808 sorry 1808
for five minutes we will be back at
18 13.
chairman thank you um thank you uh
welcome back
everyone um i won't go through the
housekeeping again as it's only been
five minutes i do apologize
for the gap but we do in fact have mr
ford so he will be able to speak
in person but first we will have the
presentation please thank you that's ms
bowles isn't it
thank you chair
planning permission is sought for the
removal of condition 2 on a 2014
application
which granted permission for a
replacement dwelling at the application
site
the removal of the condition will allow
for the retention of the original
dwelling
which is proposed to be used as
ancillary accommodation
to the replacement dwelling
and here we have the location plan um it
should be noted that the red light the
red outline indicates the land within
the
ownership of the applicant and does not
represent the residual
residential cartilage
here you can see the replacement
dwelling and here is the original
dwelling proposed to be retained
the elevations of the original dwelling
the floor and roof plans
and as part of the justification for the
retention of the original dwelling the
applicant has proposed to surrender
their permitted development rights under
class a
of the gpdo this illustrative plan
indicates
what they believe could lawfully be
built under permitted development
however as discussed within paragraphs
5.2.7 and 5.2.8
of the report a lawful development
certificate to confirm if the proposed
extension shown on the plan
would be lawful has not been submitted
and it was not as it was not considered
necessary to remove these permitted
development rights at the time of
approving the replacement dwelling
this would not justify the retention of
the original dwelling
and we've got some sight photos you can
see the original the original dwelling
along the top
the area to the rear of the original
dwelling
and the access the access track which
provides
um access to the original dwelling and
the replacement dwelling
which you can see in the distance then
we have some photos of the replacement
dwelling
i've got more pictures of the
replacement dwelling
and a view of the original dwelling from
from the road
and an aerial view which shows the level
of built form currently on the site
the application site lies outside of the
settlement boundaries of the district
where policies of restraint apply
in order to protect the intrinsic
character and beauty of the countryside
it should be free from unnecessary
development
a lack of justification and evidence has
been provided to support the removal of
the condition
as highlighted within the report the
replacement dwelling accommodates
an integral annex and the proposal fails
to comply with the criteria set out in
the specialist housing
needs spd for annex accommodation for a
number of reasons
which includes the failure to
demonstrate that the original dwelling
would be
used in a in an ancillary nature the
retention of the original dwelling would
result in the site appearing to occupy
two residential dwellings
resulting in an intrusion and
intensification of the residential
development
eroding character and appearance of the
rural site and area
therefore for these reasons the
application is recommended for refusal
thank you chair thank you
in line with the public politician's
participation scheme
um i will invite mr ford in just a
moment oh
are we already do we have the timer on
screen please
yes chairman um i have a two minute
timer set up
thank you very much can we do you put
that on a shared screen
so that no no you'll just hear it
we will just hear it okay thank you so
mr ford you will hear
an alarm sound at the end of your two
minutes and
as always i do stick to that absolutely
rigidly
so mr ford in your own time please start
and that's when we'll start the timer
thank you chairman and thanks for the
operation for the technical issues
uh planning permission to replace the
original cottages presented in 2014
condition two required demolition of the
cottage following occupation of the new
dwelling
rather unusually the current application
seeks to retain the original cottage but
there's a very good reason why
the main reason is it wasn't realised at
the time of granting the 2014 commission
that the original cottages of
17th century origin this was discovered
by the council's conservation officer
who in view of the historic providence
of the building was keen to see it
retained
the application is further accompanied
by an independent heritage assessment
which indeed confirms the dwelling
is worthy of listing the cottage has
been previously extended and some
additions and alterations have not
been undertaken sympathetically however
in seeking the dwelling's retention the
applicant will make restitutional
enhancements including
replacing the upvc windows with
historically appropriate windows
removing the modern conservatory
and carefully repointing the external
brickwork
the council's conservation officer tim
has provided a consultation response
which raises no objection to welcoming
the attention of the dwelling and
supporting the enhancements
similarly the parish council support the
proposal to retain the dwelling
they have requested a condition as
imposed that restricts the dwelling
transit
now this condition is acceptable to the
african and the application is
accompanied by unilateral undertaking
confirming the dwelling will be
ancillary to the main house in
perpetuity
and cannot be sold separately in
addition in granting the planning finish
with a
replacement dwelling and the council did
not remove the new dwelling pd rights
uh six pdf sensors are considerably
greater in scale and massive than the
original cottage
and would be more apparent in the
landscape such as
it is proposed to surrender these
generous pd rights to give something
back
and hence further shift the balance in
favor of granting planning permission
now the cottage is particularly well
screened from public viewpoints and its
historic importance is worthy of
protection in the public interest
this is
[Music]
i'm grateful i'll stop talking thank you
very much okay thank you very much mr
ford and um
goodbye hope you enjoy the rest of the
meeting uh right
miss uh councillor durham you actually
called that in as
board member casey's in your award isn't
it yours and council
jarvis so i'll let you start unless you
prefer to wait
no i i i did um call this in chairman
but it does
prove to be a dilemma um
and uh i i called it in because
uh there were circumstances whereby i
didn't think that
perhaps the full case had been looked
into
however i'm very very concerned
about a precedent in this case um
we very often we have applications for
uh replacement of existing dwellings and
um that is the norm the the condition is
that the existing building is
removed i'm aware of several cases
particularly
locally some in in the village where i
live
where some subsequent applications had
been made
to retain the existing building and all
of those
um were refused and i have to
i have to therefore um
stand up for the policies in our local
development plan
and that effectively makes this a new
dwelling
i also have to ask myself if we were
faced with the
just the new dwelling in isolation and
there was an application
for this uh assay new
annex would we have granted it and i
suspect not so um i'm
very i'm keeping my um my mind
open i'd like to hear what other
people's views are
but i i members will know
my um strenuous defense of the local
development plan
and at the moment that is the direction
that i'm going thank you
right um i do have councillor bamford to
speak but
i have a question from councillor
fleming so i
i that might be pertinent to all of us i
hope council vancouver let me ask
councillor fleming her question
thank you chair i just wanted to ask the
officers
why when permission was granted why um
the replacement dwelling wasn't uh
cited on the original house basically
what why
um you know why it was set somewhere
back
but i understand the norm would be to
agree to it being
removed and then the replacement
dwelling to go on the same footprint
albeit slightly larger would that be the
case matt
do you chairman not necessarily no in
most instances the
physicality means that that has to be a
situation but um
as councillor dom's explaining we do get
a number per year
of applications like this and that's why
the condition requiring the demolition
um obviously
sites may change land uses may change
over the years and
the historic sighting of the age welding
which may have been logical at the time
may change so when
people look to redevelop a site they do
at times look to relocate the site
there's nothing in our policy that
objects to that
it just requires that we retain one
dwelling on site
so that's why we always use the
condition that has been used in this
case
thank you chairman i hope that such a
question yeah thank you
it's not uncommon in fact not least
because sometimes people
need to live in the one while they build
the other and then move
right south council bamford please
thank you chairman um i just want to
query
the proposal because the proposal is the
removal
of condition two which is the demolition
of the existing dwelling
um but also there in the proposal it
says the variation of condition two
and i assume that that work
that variation has been done its new
detached double garage conversion of
existing bungalow garage to residential
family room
so because we've already agreed that
condition too
that work presumably has already carried
been carried out anyway
i just want to clarify that or are we
are being asked to
change something else thank you
mr lane thank you chairman um
this is where things can get a little
bit complicated in planning um
the grant of planning permission
obviously creates permission
there's a suite of conditions normally
imposed to get it when you
apply to barrier condition as we use the
terminology vary condition you're
actually
applying to not to undertake development
not in compliance with that condition
so in this case the 2009 commission
um had a condition in relation to
um probably a reality at the time it
would have been
um plans because that's traditionally
what condition two is
subsequently in 2014 an application was
submitted to vary that condition
so in reality it removed that condition
and imposed a new one
so that condition meant that the
applicant in reality could either build
out a permission that was granted in
2009
or commission was built right in 2014.
what i'm guessing and it is a informed
guess
is that the reason this has become
condition two was that a shovel
of the 2009 permission had been put in
the ground
and that would also be logical because
of the fact that five years had passed
when a permission only lasts for three
so that original condition condition one
which is must be complied within three
years would have
disappeared so the 2009 permission
condition three probably was
must get rid of the house that moved up
one
in the 2014 commission so the
the whole building and everything has
been built the dwelling has been
occupied
and they should have demolished the
current or the original dwelling
if members or officers decision makers
would grant an application such this
officers need to go through all the
original conditions that were put in on
the 2014 permission
to see which ones are still fit for
purpose and should be retained
and also impose any additional
conditions so in this case it would be
something such as
obtaining the annex trouble is obviously
as
officer's report is we don't think it
can be ancillary but in theory that's
the idea
so we would remove any conditions that
have no longer fit for purpose if any
and we would impose any new conditions
that were required due to changing
circumstances or the
implications of this application i hope
that's
sort of explained the question probably
a bit too long-winded than you needed
thanks a lot i think i've got it
counselor
can i come back because i didn't really
understand
um what i was trying to say
was if this committee was mindful of
overturning what the officers are
recommending
would that cause an issue with this
variation
of condition two where works presumably
have been completed
through each other let's try to explain
the the 2000 the variate
we're we're looking at an application
that is a ver
is a variation to a 2014 permission
that's description was a variation to a
2009 permission
so there are two permissions in
existence one from 2009
2014. this would vary the 2014
permission to create a
application from this year it wouldn't
cause any issues in relation to the
development
that has been built because as i said we
would go through the condition to see
which was still fit for purpose
certain ones would fall away and no
longer be relevant but it wouldn't cause
any issue in that respect
this application solely matter of
consideration
is the retention of the existing
dwelling acceptable or not
thank you chairman thank you thank you
thank you
can i just come back to say that
you know that wasn't clear in the report
that's why i asked and i just wondered
why
you'd made that point of putting this
detail of the variation of condition 2
in the proposal that's why i queried it
because it doesn't mention anything
about this in the actual report
so i just queried whether there was
something
that we needed to consider but obviously
you've explained it very well matt thank
you very much i understand now
thank you uh right next to speak i have
councillor jarvis who is the other ward
members
if we're talking about hazley so council
thank jarvis very much chairman members
um i do remember this application coming
up at the parish so i had the
opportunity to listen then to
some debate on it and uh i've obviously
read
read the report i've got a few questions
can we just look at the photograph again
um just to sort of get a feel for the
size of the property
the annex compared to the new build just
so i think there was one photograph
aerial photograph that showed that katie
yes that would be helpful please
continue
or whoever was keeping that please
i'm sorry thank you
so i was looking at the sort of love
rights photograph there
um i think if i'm right the the the i
don't know if you've got a pointer
system
you can use or not but i'm just sort of
trying to identify um oh thank you this
sort of cottage
which is now being they're asking for it
to be etc yes
that's the sort of size of the cottage
and the size of the new property
is obviously the new property the new
build
that's obviously basically the rest of
it okay so just to
get things in proportion um you know the
the the old cottage which the applicant
is asking
could that be used as a sort of annex is
significantly smaller
um than the new
would it be helpful if you went audio
only
[Music]
jarvis would it be helpful could you
leave and come back
or try turning off your videos
it would be a strong objection chairman
he can't leave it
right right counselor jarvis sorry
you've become clearer again
um but i'm afraid we missed rather a lot
of what you said for the last couple of
minutes
oh okay sorry it wasn't apparent to me
that i had gone anywhere
um i was really just talking about the
size of the old property uh
compared to the new property and i was
asking officer lee if he could sort of
comment
as to uh had the original had the
application for the new development
included
uh the old cottages and annex does he
think that would have caused
uh considerable harm to the countryside
essentially
mr lee actually would find the previous
slide of photos quite helpful too if we
could flip to that one
so mr lee thank you chairman um
i think obviously there's two issues
obviously our policy accepts the
demolition of an exist of a existing
dwelling and replacement with a new one
whether that's on site or whether that
is you know cheap cheek and jaw or you
know somewhere different in the side
um the policy obviously then therefore
requires that and therefore
my opinion obviously well not obviously
but i wasn't here in 2009
um and while i was in 2014 i was only in
southeast i wasn't
dealing with either of these
applications so i don't know any detail
specifically but my professional opinion
would be that
an objection would have been raised
either all of those applications because
this application would have resulted
into the appearance of two dwellings
within the site which is contrary to
policy
the fact that the property is much
smaller than the
existing property shouldn't be a
consideration for the termination this
application
the point of principle because to take
this slightly perversely and just to
take
to take members minds through this that
would be similar to arguing that
if you had a very large property we
should be allowing them all to build an
extra dwelling in their prop in their
land
because it's a lot smaller so it's not a
problem so that's the sort of
thought process of this you know the
fact that there would be two dwellings
on this property
on this plot of land however big the
plot of land is is contrary to policy
and goes to the heart of what our
policies look to resist secondly the
other thing is highlighted within the
office report is
the need for the annex to be ancillary
there has to be a strong relationship
between the main dwelling and an
ancillary use that's why there's no
case laws clear that just because there
are all the day-to-day facilities for
um living doesn't stop it from being an
annex but you should still be able to
strongly
interrelate so meals should be still be
taken in the main dwelling
um you would not normally expect it to
be a dwelling of
this scale in respect of how much
smaller it is it is still a relatively
large property
and um officers
and myself included are very written to
support a scheme of this scale as an
ancillary nature on the simple fact that
it
is an ancillary therefore a condition
required to be on the city would be
perverse
it wouldn't actually arguably work we
could end up in a situation where
actually
legally by allowing this we're
automatically creating a dwelling
because the condition doesn't meet the
sixth test and if
and if we impose a condition that
doesn't meet one of the six tests which
are laid out through law
that condition just disappears it
doesn't exist it's
um found to be unreasonable no six art
tests are
necessary well yes it is precise
yes it is we could word that um
is it enforceable well that's where it
gets a bit questionable because of the
fact that actually it's not instantly in
the first place
um is it relevance planning well yes it
would be
is it relevant to the permit development
yes is it um
reasonable well no because they've
actually it can't be done so
for two reasons that condition wouldn't
meet the test so it
basically wouldn't exist so what we
would be granting
is a new dwelling on this site however
they may interrelate
the occupier today i'm not trying to you
know as quite often as you know i
sometimes think people think i'm trying
to say applicants are lying or they're
bending the truth or anything and i'm
not and i never am but planning has to
look at the lifetime of the development
so irrespective of how the applicant may
wish to use that building today
tomorrow next year circumstances change
owners change
physical situations change and what
would happen is in reality in 5
10 15 days weeks years however long
we would end up in within a separate
wedding where it would be very hard to
be able to say that sorry
policy a condition which stops that and
that's the reality of the situation
that's why this officer's report goes
into quite detail on that and tries to
explain that matter
and i hope i've done it some justice
thank you chairman
thank you thank you can i just come back
on that chairman
yes yes yes thank you absolutely that
one that was obviously very well
explained
it's just that looking at it it
obviously seems a great shame
if there is a small 17th century cottage
that doesn't look to be a huge plot on
the landscape so to speak
that obviously would be used it seems a
shame to
um to have to um the conservation of
officers are happy and the parish is
happy
it seems a shame to um to sort of insist
on it being knocked down
um because it doesn't sort of
measure up to those sort of planning
policies although i appreciate that very
important
i just wonder if um you know there is a
way around it sounds to me as if you're
saying
the applicant would be better off in
some way asking for
permission for the the old dwelling to
be a new dwelling i'm just wondering if
there's a way around it because
from what you're saying if you feel
there isn't um and the property
needs to be taken down that just seems
seems a shame that there isn't a way
around that because it doesn't look
a considerable property and it doesn't
look as if it's very intrusive on the
countryside
and i'm very much as you know a believer
in looking at each case
on its own merits and i think in this
case you know looking at it from a sort
of
common sense point of view i realize
that's not necessarily the same as
planning
um but from a common sense point of view
it looks um a bit of a shame
to insist on 17th century property being
knocked down
but um i hear what you say thank you
very much your comments opposite thank
you
thank you councilman jarvis um i do have
councillor durham waiting to come back
but
just looking at this photo is it
possible to tell which bits of
the original building were
were original and which bits are
extensions because
i would never look at that and think
17th century cottage
three chairman i'm just trying to read
through the consultation response and
um to i'm you know i haven't read for it
all because in detail but one of the
sentences that's just jumped at me right
in the middle of the first paragraph
is the overall significance of the house
is limited because of the degree to
which it has been altered in the 20th
century
all evidence for original openings has
been obscured by later
alterations indeed at a glance the house
has been
has the appearance of an unexceptional
mid-20th century dwelling
so i would think that maybe
um the applicant has tried to
push forward the historic significance
of the building as a material
consideration at a greater way than
maybe officers would recommend that we
considered it as
that would be my advice remember that
and if you actually yeah read
mr houston's response it isn't
particularly favorable of retaining the
dwelling for its historic impact
thank you thank you well i was almost
wondering
if i was looking at the right building
however um councillor darren please come
back
well thank you very much chairman and
yes i i i think mr lee's explanation is
is excellent um the house where i'm
sitting
um goes back to that sort of time but
the bit i'm sitting in
uh is uh 20th stroke 21st century
and and i think that is a very tenuous
excuse
i think we have to ask ourselves a
couple of things the
the the owners when they have made the
application for the new dwelling will
have known will have been fully aware
that it would have been a criteria to
remove the existing dwelling because
they're applying for
and i quote a replacement dwelling
so that is you sacrifice one for the
other now we see
dozens and dozens and dozens of these um
particularly actually in the wick and
bishops area where it's the removal of
the original building
and uh the the the owner continues to
live in
that until the new one is built and then
they knock down
uh the existing the other point i'd like
to make is that
ignoring the building that is there if
the owners of the new property
applied for an annex and and the reason
that most people apply for an annex is
if they have elderly or infirm
um relations or whatever and they want
them very close at hand
would that be the size and scale of
what is there now no it wouldn't and it
would be very much ancillary and
and with the best will in the world
there is no physical way that this can
realistically be ancillary to the main
building
so i is with a heavy heart and and i
don't like seeing things
demolished but this would have been uh
the the understanding right from word go
and that to say that it's you know uh
17th century i mean you know let's look
at it it's
it says in mr lee's words unexceptional
i'd say it's very unexceptional nice
house and all that but
um to to overturn on
this that it has historic value even the
conservation officer
acknowledges the fact that what was
there once
is now hidden if not destroyed so i
honestly think
that there is no way that this could be
regarded as being ancillary and um
i'm leaning strongly towards that view
thank you chairman
thank you um i'd also add certainly
in in my ward i can think of one that
was
quoted twice as a replacement dwelling
so it's actually a two for one and it's
still there
um and another one where there was an
application to rebuild on the original
site even though
another dwelling had been built so
yes i'm very unhappy about the prospect
of this day i must say
so um no one else is asked to speak so i
will in fact i usually do this earlier
but i will in fact put the officers
oh sorry um sorry i expected to see you
on the chat
sorry uh castle white please i didn't
mean to cut you out
that's okay thank you uh momentum just
to say that i was shadowing
uh my ward member at the time this
application came up so although i didn't
sit on the committee
i remember it very well and i seem to
recall
from the correspondence that he received
that the reason they wanted to build
nanics was it was difficult to access
it was damp it was cold it was um
impractical
to um bring it up to date
hence they wanted a modern building that
was going to be easily maintained so
that was the first one
um now normally i support houses in the
countryside normally i try and
support rural villages because i think
growth is good
but we've had so many of these
applications over the years where
we've agreed to move the dwellings
generally into the middle of a field or
middle of a plot and i've generally
supported them um but then quite a few
of them come back
and so we want to now keep the original
and i'm going to stand by what we've
always done in these
um these cases is say
well no because we only got permission
for the new one because you were going
to surrender the old one
um and the other thing is under 5.2.2
um this isn't even on the non-designated
heritage sites
um which they you know it could have
been or if it was
of merit it should have been even if it
didn't merit listing
so for me i i actually can't support
this i think it's being a bit cheeky
because it's um you know but back in the
day
they actually said the house wasn't um
suitable to live in and it was too
expensive
to um bring it up to date and yet
suddenly
i don't know what 11 years later
it's perfectly right and there's no
mention of it so so you know they were
saying it needed to be demolished in
2009
so i could only go by that i expect that
it needs to be demolished um
and we will set a difficult precedent
because we won't be able to defend
any of the future um ones going forward
where we allow a replacement dwelling
and as i say
i'm not the person who supports rural
dwellings but in this case
i think it would be dangerous to support
it and i agree with the officer's
recommendation
thank you that's helpful um right there
members i
don't believe i've missed anyone else um
so i'm going to put the officer's
recommendation do i have a seconder
yes i'll second that thank you lots of
lights came on sorry who was first
oh well i think i might have been okay
yeah um right um let's put that
to the vote i think we'd better do a
roll call from judging by the
various opinions i've heard so uh katie
could we do a roll call please we are
voting on the officer's recommendation
to refuse
thank you chairman so we're voting to
refuse the application as per the
officer's recommendation
members i'll take your names in
alphabetical order please could you
indicate whether you are for against or
abstain
starting with councillor bamford please
four
thank you councillor durham
four thank you councillor mrs fleming
full thank you councillor jarvis
that's right heavy heart four thank you
councillor morley
thank you abstain
thank you councillor mrs thompson paul
thank you councillor miss white
paul thank you
thank you chairman that is seven for
none against and one abstention
thank you so uh that leaves that
application for lodge farm
uh is refused in line with the office's
recommendation thank you right
um the next item is the tpo
at the warren golf club so council
dharma chairman uh
yes having declared an interest i will
now leave you have a lovely evening
you'll be pleased to hear there is no
urgent business so we won't need to see
you back
i'm very glad to uh hear that and thank
you chairman thank you members see you
on the other side
quite so thank you councillor darren
uh so we're agender item six which is
the tree preservation order
six twenty slash twenty one golf club
including bunsen downs and badges uh
wooden wall says found on pages
27-34 um
in a moment i'll call on the officer to
present the item members a reminder that
if you wish to speak on this item please
make it known using the
chat function um
as you've spotted i'm not necessarily
that good at um
seeing the hands out but um please
challenge me if i miss you
um here we go mr parker haynes please
i think yes i've got the council about
in october 2018 the council received
reports of inappropriate and unjustified
arboricultural works taking place within
the warren estate
these works were considered to put the
trees at risk and an initial
tempo assessment scored the area of
trees 23 out of 25
and concluded that the woodland was
worthy of a tree preservation order
and an area tpo was served on the 29th
of october 2018
however following further site visits by
the modern district council's tree
consultant and a planning officer
specific trees
groups of trees and woodlands worthy of
retention were identified
the emergency tpi was therefore revoked
and a new more specific tpo
4 of 19 was served on the 26th of april
2019.
the tempo assessment scored the more
specific tpo 20 out of 25 and concluded
that the woodland was worthy of a true
preservation order
consequently as a result of further site
visits following additional
inappropriate works having been carried
out and the loss of several trees due to
weather conditions
tpo 4 of 19 was revoked and tpi 6 of 20
was served
one objection was received and has not
been resolved and therefore the question
of
whether or not to confirm the tpo has
been brought before members to decide
this is an aerial overlay of the tpo map
here are some photos of the trees from
within the street scene
here are some photos of the trees within
the site
and here are some examples of some
inappropriate works which have been
carried out after serving the first
initial tpi
given the maturity of the trees and the
prominent location within the estate and
surrounding area it is considered that
this woodland landscape plays a
significant role in underscoring the
value of the visual amenity of the
surrounding area
it's their recommend for recommended
that the true preservation order is
confirmed
thank you chairman thank you um
right we don't have anyone to speak on
this um
and we don't well we do have a tree
expert but
she's actually uh an amateur counselor
white
um right who would like to speak
first well i'm happy to speak on this
one
i seem to be involved there's a lot
sorry i have got i'm a politic i must
apologize i've got councillor bamford
well hang on yes councillor bamford
councillor jarvis
councillor morley sorry oh but i will
come to you councillor white of course
council banford
sorry chairman i thought you were going
to take councillor white first
um i just wanted to ask the officers
um at the point of 3.1.3
in this report it says the objections
remain
unresolved and that's why it's come to
this committee
um i just want to have some kind of
explanation really
um as to why these objections remain
unresolved and why we've having to
look at this as a committee
mr link oh
do you channel just scrolling down to
that section
um
that would be the golf course objective
yep i'll just assume so sorry
no i internet's having some trouble
that's why you're looking mr lee my
question would have
been if we had a trade officer isn't
what exactly was inappropriate i mean
they
certainly some bowels were locked off
but you know was there a reason why
they're dead where they're dangerous
oh sweetie chairman for that my
understanding is that
um the technique for one of a better
word that was used was rather the
arbitrary it wasn't meeting the accepted
british standards for works to
trees okay thank you
as the poor explains they haven't
entered into a
formal sort of plan to manage the trees
or anything per se and it
does seem to be a little bit ad hoc and
yeah the true office is quite concerned
about some of the quality of the work
that he's been undertaking on
the site um sorry about what
is it sorry mr lee and
councillor um thompson i can come back
and answer that in a bit more
in depth if you'd like in relation to
the wounded
as long as we do get the answer to
councillor bamford's
question at some point you know
what
in relation to the inappropriate works
they've left
large open wounds um which the tree
won't be able to seal
which then leaves the tree open and
vulnerable to decay
and the formation of the branch is near
the center of the tree so if the decay
establishes at these points it can then
easily extend to the centre of the tree
which in turn compromises the structural
integrity and longevity of the tree
thank you okay thank you
do we have an answer on the objection
beyond the common sense one do we have
any more details
yeah do you chairman um paragraph seven
point one point one of the officers
report it
goes through the uh
the requirements yep i've got two um
that's why not requirements uh
goes through the uh objection um
some of them to be honest a little bit
outdated and they're discrete but they
are
taken through there i'll if members want
to just
i'll give members a couple of minutes
they want just to familiarize themselves
with that points rather than me just
reading it out to them
yes that makes sense thank you members
of you chairman
sorry chairman may i just come back
because i have read
the report i just want to know why
those objections have are unresolved
i can see the objections but why why are
they
resolved why have we had to consider it
is what i really wanted to know
i don't know chairman um
obviously delegated authority only sits
with the officers if there are no
unresolved objections so normally that
means objections with the uh
objections are quite minor in nature um
as you can see certain things such as
saying there is no scale well actually
officers don't agree with that there is
a scale and they do think
it's workable um and actually just don't
say anything that
objection may sit with a previous report
um
like in relation to how the tree should
that's the
second option
or point you know officers have said
there's not a statute requirement when
serving the tpo to do this and we've
given the scale the site and it the mac
provider is considered suitable detail
has been provided
um they're saying that because the
failing license
that we shouldn't necessarily have to be
a tpo
obviously we've gone into detail why
that's not they are totally separate
pieces of legislation how
and also there are concerns about the
validity of social comment anyway in
relation to the
valid uh vetting license so one of the
better phrase
the officers and all the council and the
applicant have not been able to come to
a reasonable compromise on these points
the app
the owner of the trees or or the owner
of some of the majority of these
triggers you know
we're all aware it's more than one that
land owner but the
the golf course have objected and
we haven't been able to satisfy their
concerns which
um i i think just slightly
unreasonable expectations maybe and some
uninformed opinion on relation to the
failing license but for that reason
we have to bring it to four members to
confirm the tpo
thank you chairman thank you thank you
chairman
does that mean that the applicant might
have a right to appeal
the only way to um challenge the servant
of a tpa would be through a judicial
review which would be to say that
the council has done something legally
in the
so illegally in the process of serving
the tpo which was certainly saying
becomes a moot point because it's quite
formalic um
once the tpo is served though is the
applicant would have a
right to submit
an application for works
for the tree if the
council refused them then they would
have a
right to that to appeal against that
decision but
there isn't any reque expectation that
we would say no to works happening in
the future
it's just that after some of the uh
recent
work that has been undertaken there are
concerns
about the trees their longevity and the
need to protect them
so there is no right appeal for the
serving of the tpo
but there is obviously against if we
refuse any of the works but i think
that's covered in section 4.2 of the
office reports
well some detail but hopefully i've
explained it a little bit more detail
than in that section
thank you thank you very much matt thank
you chairman
thank you um just a quick quick question
mr lee um
should little bit you know should the
tpl be agreed
and um works were required by the tree
owners would that be
relatively minor works would that need
to come back to committee or is that
something that could be
it's delegated and dealt with by the
tree officer
really chairman um oh we'll see all
tpo's works start off as delegated to
the council
to officers yeah um so there wouldn't it
be any need for
any of these works i wouldn't have
thought to come back for committee but i
do know
mr parker haynes has he's ranked i don't
she wants to expand on something i've
said if that's where you chairman
thank you thank you tim and that was an
old hand sorry
ah okay a legacy hand right i have
missed
councilman oh no how counselor jarvis
next sorry
i don't apologize everybody i'm getting
lost on the list
thanks gentlemen um yeah we i
was sort of trying to take all this in
but i mean i think really we're looking
at a whole range of tbos that quite
clearly
should be being enforced and you've got
one objective which is the golf course
owner
seems to be merely chopping down
branches probably in relation
to the golf course and golf activities
perhaps
in a way which has been described by
professionals as not a very appropriate
way
so i'm struggling to find
that there could be any uh sensible
argument
um to to do anything other than
to reinforce that the tpos
should be in place and that we should
defend them and uh
i'm struggling to see any argument uh
that would uh that would convince me
otherwise
thank you councilman
yes thank you chairman um pretty much
with your question actually council
thompson you are
you were sort of asked really and it was
just the
the inappropriate um
with the trees but what was it a safety
reason
that that was the thing but i think
that's been answered thank you
thank you yes i mean i understand that
a branch may have to go if there's a
safety aspect but it was
um if it's if we're talking about the
way it's been done then
my inclination is to say then yes we
need to maintain the tpo i agree
i agree um any anybody else sorry
miss white that didn't wish to know
something like that
yes that's okay manchester um just to
say
i i generally don't support tpos um
i will make a note that on this one they
are actually trees rather than scrubs so
that's an improvement
and i do have some slight concerns
um when the ejector is saying that um
it's difficult to note which trees are
covered
um what i would say is if it doesn't tie
in
with um aerial photographs
should we defer this and redo the
paperwork so it's accurate
and that's my only thought because they
are trees
so i don't have an ejection because they
are trees but i would have a problem if
it's not accurate because i know from
experience it's difficult to find out
which trees are covered so i do think
to be fair to the landowners and in case
it goes to appeal
that we can say for certainty which
trees are covered and that this map will
actually identify
which trees and areas are covered
because it's not fair on the owner
if it is ambiguous i mean i don't know i
i don't know well enough whether you
could tell but
but i don't like the idea of an
ambiguous um map
okay per question mr lee do you think
chairman i think it's very fair question
actually
because obviously the scale of the site
we've been quite conscious of the
ability to
actually accurately um
delineate and clearly identify the trees
and mr park
can you show that aerial photograph that
you've got
that's showing the simplest one
so um we batch as you can see here
i think this is an extract there's any
possibility of enlarging that
i've i've zoomed in as much as i can on
the actual
power point but i can zoom in on
specific areas and hopefully move it
around and that should allow
if i might come in on my ipad i can just
make it bigger with my fingers
it just just just opens up yeah that's
what i'm doing i'm lucky
but what i was going to say as officers
we actually knocked myself personally
but we have actually used gps to go down
and to actually
make sure that this is very clear and
accurate because one of the we have had
that objection before
when on one of the previous note uh tpos
we served as mrs park haines explained
and
whilst we didn't think it was unusable
we did have we did
feel some sympathy for the applicants
we've actually gone a little bit above
and beyond that we would have done to
actually make this quite clear so i
think
out of any tpo in the whole district
this is the one that we are most sure
that you'd be able to clearly delineate
and make sure is most accurate
with the exception of one that might be
like an oak when there's only one oak
tree in the front garden or something
but otherwise i would say that this is
for something like this this is as good
as it's going to get thank you chairman
okay um thank you i take some comfort
from that uh councillor jarvis wanted to
come back oh councillor why is this
a legacy hand oh yes sorry it's legacy
or did you want to come back okay
councillor jarvis please yeah thank you
chairman i just wanted to ask i saw a
reference to a sort of five-year plan
which sounds
very sensible um could um obviously just
comment on whether
um the golf course owners of um
engaged at all in agreeing or a sort of
plan a five-year plan i mean
or is this something that we have asked
for and they just haven't responded
could he just comment on that because
that seems to be perhaps what's missing
it um
three channels i've not been privileged
to the conversation so i wouldn't want
to go too far but my understanding is
that
officers have been quite clear in the
fact that um
a long-term sort of management plan
would be something that
we would be looking for would help us in
being confident of the
management of the trees going forward
and that hasn't come forward but
as the officers report explains that can
actually even be they can submit one of
them
under a tpo anyway so um we have
tried to get something like that but
nothing like that has been come forward
at the moment but i won't really want to
say much more than that
thank you chairman thank you i'm sorry
councilman your video
by the way i don't know i don't know if
your microphone is
through you thank you also i think i
mean that's very disappointing really
um i find if they don't sound as if
they're being very cooperative
um it's surely fairly easy to be
cooperative on this sort of thing
so that is disappointing thank you thank
you
sorry councilwoman did you want to come
back
where was that
legacy just just to say that um if the
um is accurate which it does appear to
be that i'm okay because they are trees
but i do want to be certain that no
scrub is covered and as long as mr lee
can confirm that for me because
if there's any scrub in there then i
will absolutely object so as long as
it's trees and that's in
confirmed then i'm okay with it um
uh yes i'm confident i got that
confirmation so
mr lee yes
no yes do you chairman
yeah these trees obviously there are
woodland ones but yeah
it's trees fine thank you
uh right i haven't anyone else wishing
to speak have i missed anyone
so i will put the officer recommendation
which is to
confirm just make sure i get the right
wording
obviously place but yes i'm putting the
recommendation to
confirm tree preservation order dpo 6-20
without any modifications
do i have a second out
thank you all right i'll counsel bamford
first but thank you for
all of us um
i guess we'd better have a roll call but
i think i can see which way it's going
but
miss katie could we please have a roll
call
thank you chairman so we're voting um to
confirm the tpo
without modification members if you
could i'll take your names in
alphabetical order
please could you indicate whether you
are fought against or abstain
starting with councillor bamford please
four
thank you councillor oh no no
he went councillor mrs fleming oh
thank you councillor jarvis
you're muted counselor apologies
for thank you thank you
councillor morley four
thank you councillor siddall
four thank you councillor mrs thompson
paul thank you councillor miss white
thor thank you
chairman that's seven for
none against and no abstentions thank
you very much
so that tree preservation order is um
confirmed
uh item seven on the agenda is any other
items of business the chairman
of the committee decides are urgent as
i've already said there are none
so in a moment i will close the meeting
but again i'm going to repeat my thanks
to the officers
all the officers of all departments
thank you very much for all your hard
work
over the year in a chunk um
thank you members for your take you know
all your contributions
um i'm going to draw this meeting to a
close
at 19 10.
thank you all as the meeting is now
closed